IN THROUGHOUT THE SHOW.
DIFFERENT GRAPHICS AND STUFF,
THAT SHOULD BE FUN.
ON A LESS FUN NOTE, WHAT IS
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IN BROOKLYN.
LET'S DIVE IN.
6-7 SINCE JANUARY 1st.
AND KEVIN DURANT RIGHT NOW IS
OUT.
KYRIE IRVING PLAYED HIS FIRST
GAME ON JANUARY 5th, 4-3 WITH
HIM IN THE LINEUP.
BUT THE DURANT INJURY, IT'S NOW
DOWN TO THREE TO FIVE WEEKS WITH
THE MCL SPRAIN.
AND REPORTS THAT JAMES HARDEN IS
TELLING PLAYERS AND COACHES THAT
HE'S GOING TO TEST FREE AGENCY
THIS SUMMER.
CITING THINGS LIKE WEATHER,
TAXES, HAVING TO SHOULDER THE
LOAD OUT K.D.
EVEN MENTIONED THINGS LIKE STEVE
NASH'S ROTATIONS.
I MEAN, IT WAS A LOT OF
INFORMATION THAT CAME OUT.
>> HE SAID WEATHER AND TAXES.
>> TOO MANY LIGHTS.
>> THERE WAS A LOT OF STUFF --
>> STOPLIGHTS.
>> WHEN YOU HEAR THAT, SHAQUILLE
O'NEAL, WHAT POPS IN YOUR HEAD?
>> OBVIOUSLY, HE'S NOT HAPPY.
WHEN THE TEAM WAS FIRST PUT
TOGETHER, THEY HAD CHAMPIONSHIP
ASPIRATIONS.
NOW ONE GUY DOING HIS OWN THING,
NOBODY IS ON THE SAME PAGE.
THE FIRST THING AFTER I WANT TO
MIAMI, I HAD A MEETING WITH MY
GOOD FRIEND OVER THERE.
I SAID, I'VE JUST BEEN THROUGH A
LOT.
I DON'T WANT TO GO THROUGH IT NO
MORE.
THIS IS WHERE I WANT TO BE, WITH
YOU.
AND WE FULFILLED THAT PROMISE.
WE SHOULD HAVE WON THE FIRST
YEAR, BUT SOMETHING HAPPENED.
WE WON'T TALK ABOUT THAT.
ENDED UP WINNING THE SECOND
YEAR.
IN ORDER TO WIN A CHAMPIONSHIP,
YOU HAVE TO SACRIFICE, YOU HAVE
TO BE ON THE SAME PAGE, YOU HAVE
TO LIKE EACH OTHER.
WE FOUGHT, WE ARGUED, ME AND
D-WADE WERE IN THE LOCKER ROOM
LAUGHING.
WE NEVER YELLED AT EACH OTHER,
BUT WHEN WE SAID SOMETHING,
PEOPLE KNEW WHAT WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT.
ON THE BENCH, CALL OUT THE DAMN
SCREEN, I KNOW HE WAS TALKING TO
ME.
>> YOU DON'T THINK THEY CAN DO
THAT IN BROOKLYN RIGHT NOW?
>> WHEN YOU GOT ONE GUY DOING
HIS OWN THING --
>> KYRIE.
>> A GUY THAT IS REALLY NEEDED.
PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT THIS, DOING
THIS, DOING THAT, DOING HIS OWN
THING, IT THROWS THE BALANCE OF
HOW IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE.
WHEN WE WERE IN OUR MODE, WE HAD
ONE BALANCE, ONE VOICE, HIS
VOICE.
WE DID EVERYTHING RIGHT, BODY
FAT, PAT RILEY, ALL THAT, THE
CULTURE, ONE THING, ONE VOICE.
WE WERE ABLE TO WIN.
JAMES HARDEN MADE SOME PROMISES,
THEY'RE NOT BEING KEPT, HE SAID,
HEY, I'M OUT OF HERE THIS
SUMMER.
AND I WOULD DO THE SAME THING IF
I WAS HIM.
>> AND FOR JAMES, IT'S A SENSE
OF URGENCY.
K.D. AND KYRIE HAVE RINGS.
JAMES, HE DON'T.
JAMES IS GETTING OLDER.
WE KNOW THIS.
TO BE AS PRODUCTIVE AS JAMES IS,
HE'S PRETTY MUCH AVERAGING A
TRIPLE-DOUBLE.
I DON'T KNOW THE NUMBERS, BUT
IT'S CLOSE.
>> 22, 8, AND 10.
NUMBER ONE IN THE NBA IN
ASSISTS.
>> BESIDES HAVING THE HAMSTRING
INJURY, HE'S BEEN PRETTY
AVAILABLE MOST OF HIS CAREER.
SO THIS IS SENSE OF URGENCY TIME
FOR JAMES HARDEN.
IF HE WANTS TO TEST FREE AGENCY,
THAT'S WHAT IT'S THERE FOR.
FOR A PLAYER TO BE ABLE TO TEST
FREE AGENCY, THAT'S HIS RIGHT.
I KNOW EVERYBODY GETS HUNG UP ON
IT, SO WHAT?
HE SHOULD BE ABLE TO.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT IS GOING ON
IN THE LOCKER ROOM.
BUT WE KNOW JAMES HARDEN HAS
BEEN CONSISTENT FOR THIS TEAM.
K.D. WAS PLAYING AT AN MVP LEVEL
BEFORE HE WENT OUT.
JAMES HARDEN HAS BEEN THE ONE,
EVERY NIGHT, HE'S BEEN THERE TO
ABLE TO HELP THIS TEAM STAY
WHERE THERE, THEY ALMOST HAVE 30
WINS.
>> BUT HE'S NOT A FREE AGENT
YET.
THAT'S MY POINT.
THE FACT THAT WHEN YOU HAVE A
CONTRACT, AND YOU START A
SEASON, AND THE WHOLE POINT OF
THEM GOING THERE WAS TO WIN, WHY
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT THIS RIGHT
NOW?
>> THE MEDIA.
>> WE'RE THIRD IN THE EAST RIGHT
NOW.
TWO GAMES, WHAT, HOW MANY GAMES
OUT OF --
>> 29-17.
>> YOU'RE A HALF A GAME OUT OF
FIRST PLACE RIGHT NOW.
WITH ONE OF YOUR BEST PLAYERS
OUT WITH A KNEE INJURY, AND
KYRIE ONLY PLAYING ON THE ROAD.
SO YOU COULD GET A RING THIS
YEAR.
>> HE'S COME OUT IN THE LAST
WEEK, HE SAID THE REFS' WHISTLES
HAVEN'T BEEN CONSISTENT.
HE ALSO SAID AFTER A RECENT
GAME, WE'D REALLY LIKE KYRIE TO
BE HERE FOR ALL OF THE GAMES.
SEEMS LIKE ALL THE ISSUES ARE
COMING UP AT THE SAME TIME.
BUT IT'S THE MIDDLE OF THE YEAR,
THEY'RE A HALF GAME OUT OF
FIRST.
INTERESTING TIMING.
>> A LOT OF ATHLETES, ESPECIALLY
YOUNGER, I KNOW JAMES IS GETTING
OLDER, THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND,
THESE YEARS GO BY.
AND THE OPPORTUNITIES TO WIN
CHAMPIONSHIPS BECOME LESS AND
LESS.
WHEN YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY,
YOU'RE IN THIRD PLACE IN THE
EAST, AND A HALF A GAME --
>> WHEN THEY'RE GONE, THEY'RE
GONE.
>> HEY.
>> YOU GUYS SO